- [Male Narrator] We in
America are immigrants
or the children of immigrants.
We are one people, but a people
welded from many nations and races.
- My name is Michelle and my family
came from Scotland to Canada in 1824,
and then in the 1920s
they immigrated to the US.
- My great, great grandfather
came to the US from China
in the late 1800s
and worked on the Pacific Railroad.
- ...the Ukraine and Poland and they
came to the States in the 1890s.
- My family's from Castellammare in Italy
and came here around 1910.
- [Male Narrator] Then there are
families like this, who have suffered
a religious persecution that could
drive them from their homes.
- They immigrated to America after
surviving separate
concentration camps in 1946.
- And my mom immigrated
from Seoul, Korea in 1968.
- [Male Narrator] To the man deprived
of civil rights in his native land,
America offers the hope of freedom.
- My parents and I traveled to
the United States after the Vietnam War
from a Thai refugee camp.
- My mom came here from Nicaragua in 1979
just before the revolution broke out.
- My father's side of the
family came here by force.
They are descendants of slaves
and my mother's side of the family
came here by choice as immigrants.
- My dad is from Trinidad
and my mom is from
Guyana and they moved
here in their late 20s.
- [Male Narrator] And there are those
who have known it firsthand, the
political oppression of
autocratic governments.
- I was born in Jalalabad, Afghanistan
and I came to America
with my family in 1982.
Russia had invaded Afghanistan
at the time and millions of
Afghans fled the country.
- My parents are from northern Iraq
and my parents came to the US in 1984.
- Everything was going well until
the revolution came, then
everything turned into chaos.
My family immigrated from Iran
to Tampa, Florida in 1987.
- Well my mom came to
America from Ireland in 1987.
- My parents migrated
to Seattle, Washington
from León, Guanajuato about 30 years ago.
- My parents immigrated to this
country in 1989 from Bangladesh.
- My family and I moved to America
from Russia in the early 90s.
- My family is from India.
I came to the United States
about 10 years ago.
- My mom, my dad, myself, and my siblings,
we all moved here about 10 years ago
when I was 16 from Iran.
- [Male Narrator] Millions of
every nation and calling, drawn
together by their vision of America,
a vision of land,
opportunity, and freedom.
- I don't know how my story is
any different than the
Irish and the Germans,
and the Polish, and the Scottish
who came to America and did
absolutely amazing things.
- Both sides of the family are patriots.
They love this country.
They worked very hard for this country.
So in my opinion it doesn't really
matter how they got here,
but why they stayed.